Hello everybody, this is Dr. Conner as I want to make this video to help people understand the best
Neutraceutical approach
To what they might be experiencing as possibly long-haul
COVID type symptoms vaccine reaction type symptoms exposure to people that are vaccinated type symptoms
symptoms
Chronic infection type symptoms. What am I supposed to do?
There's a lot of different protocols out there. I think there's three distinct
And separate and somewhat opposite approaches that we need to look at depending on what your problem is
So this is to help you identify
What your problem is so let's follow along and I'm gonna try to make this as simple as possible even though there's a lot of complexity to it
So if you have to listen to it a couple times, please do so
So I'm gonna talk about three
Distinct reactions that people might be having at this point in history. What is a prolonged
immune deficiency
reaction
Two is an acute or prolonged immune enhancement and
Three is an acute or prolonged toxic reaction
So we're gonna discuss these in detail and try to break them down to help you
self-diagnose yourself
Really walk through this process in your mind maybe talk to your local
Practitioner to help you with this as well
So the first response is this prolonged
immune deficiency
This is the person that is really worn out. They feel sick. They feel flu light. Maybe they had this
thing described as
Covid several months ago and they seem to not have gotten over it
They still have no sense of smell. They still just feel exhausted. They feel like they're down in the dumps
They feel like they never get enough sleep. They feel like they could continue to sleep all day
They just never seem to have recovered from that. This is the first piece of reaction. You treat this very differently than the next two
So this is truly what might be considered long Covid type symptoms
and it can be caused from
Maybe it's the Covid that's long-standing that you're never able to overcome it. Many
Practitioners are believing that it is actually a reactivation of other latent
viruses or biotoxins in your body that you maybe have had for decades and
and
maybe never had symptoms of in the past
Epistead bar virus is one thing
There's some research articles that you can look up on this detail if you want to get really dirty about it
Lime disease that you might have been exposed to and feel like you overcame ten years ago
Now you're getting those type of symptoms again. You feel
Limey as some of my patients would say
this the exposure to
Covid this exposure to spike proteins exposure to EMF's exposure to everything that's going on right now can reactivate that thing can
Can't can't wake those viruses up that have been
Long dormant in your body. Maybe your immune system has kept them quiet and silenced them for a long period of time
Kind of get like getting a colsor again when you're exposed to
Lebed juice
Well the colsor that virus the herpes virus that causes a colsor was always living in your nerve gangly on it
Now it just had the opportunity to come out. We're getting those opportunistic type
Disorders come up that maybe we're even worse than you experienced them in the first place
That is really an immune deficiency. That's what we're talking about this first piece
These people need to support their immune system
This is where we created what we call our cold and flu bundle on our store
You can go if you don't want to buy our products
I don't care go and look up the ingredients of these these are some of the things you might already have them in products and you're covered
Look up what the ingredients are and start taking those things
You need to build up your immune system. There's other things you could do if you can identify
Yeah, this is from my Lyme disease or this is from my Epstein bar
Then go back how did you treat that Epstein bar when you had it eight years ago?
Well, I use this and this will think about adding that same product again. What worked for you?
So find out what latent disease disorder
Malady that is this is bringing to life and try to identify that if you have tools like a rife machine run programs for that thing
So that is the first piece the immune deficiency
ward out type
Issue that people get
the second distinct
Reaction is a little bit more complex and a little bit more dangerous you could say
This is the acute prolonged immune enhancement
This could happen acutely and in a severe acute enhancement
That can be called antibody dependent enhancement. It could be deadly so
Getting a vaccine that that causes an ADE an antibody dependent enhancement
You're basically firing an antibody reaction the spike proteins are attaching to
The cell membrane causing an immune reaction that's destroying the cell and it can be deadly if it's depending on where this is happening
So that's what's causing the acute pair of car dytus the myocarditis. That's what's causing inflammation of the brain
on a
More common level. It's happening more in a chronic matter
So you could say prolonged immune enhancement the slow
Chronic increase inflammation symptoms can be from unclear thinking any brain type symptoms if it's going to cause
inflammation of the brain which could be
Symptoms that are
that are affecting
Coordination symptoms that are affecting balance any hyper histamine type reactions any increase in heart rate
Respiratory type symptoms shortness and breath anxiety depression mood disorders head aches
memory issues any
Increased autoimmune symptoms the list goes on beyond this but this
Chronic inflammatory condition that's taking place it really depends on what organ area that it's taking place in a person could have
Digest chronic digestive issues chronic
Euridary issues bladder issues we could move the list could carry on
Definitely here almost this can be very dangerous because this
Increases this this hyperactivity of this immune system is increasing the
Proinflammatory cytokines so cytokines is a specific immune
Singly molecule in your body and you have proinflammatory cytokines in
Anti-inflammatory cytokines cytokines that increase inflammation inside of clients that decrease
Inflammation where we're talking about in this reaction is it increase in the proinflammatory cytokines they are way down
that
Tipping the balance of your immune response to very hyper inflation
Inflammation so your immune
Cells are completely imbalanced you have a hyper immune response
Different inflammatory cytokines like interleukin six and interleukin 23 actually block what are called T reg cells
T reg cells are regulate the immune system and help bring it into balance
But they're blocked by these proinflammatory cytokines and you develop this
imbalance into the degree this is imbalanced is the degree that you'll have symptoms like I said if this is in an acute
Proinflammatory hyper inflammatory state to a severe degree it can lead to death
So but for most people it won't cause sudden death it will just cause
Chronic inflammation chronic autoimmune disease
Chronic pain chronic headaches chronic shortness of breath chronic ill ease
dis ease in your body
So you have to calm that down
So the goal is to calm that down
Where is it going to affect you it's going to affect you anywhere these by proteins could be anywhere
That this inflammation could be typically it's going to be worse in previously damaged tissue
So if you have any previous injury you're going to end up with an enhancement more so in that area
An example perfect example of that is in the brain
So in the brain if you have a post-concussive issue in the past maybe you played soccer or football as a
As a youngster and you had multiple concussions or you headed the ball all the time and you had some
Some maybe nothing that knocked you out but some minor little concussions
Well, you're going to have some damage to the cells in the brain called the microglial cells and then
An insult like this that's going to increase pro-inflammatory cytokines
Throughout your whole body
Systemically is going to increase those pro-inflammatory cytokines in that already previously damaged
Though you've been able to cope with it
area of your body in this example the brain and you have more inflammation on those microglial cells and
An increase
Issue now with brain you have increased memory issue increase issue with depression or anxiety it just it just um
Exacerbates a condition that you once kind of had under control
So that's what we see with this type of thing
It actually gets worse. It's made worse if there's a greater amount of
Electromagnetic frequency exposure. So if you're exposed to a lot of dangerous EMFs
There's studies that show that this even makes it worse
So you have this inflammation you already might have damaged tissue from previous injury
Now you have an increase in pro-inflammatory cytokines and you're exposed to a lot of EMFs
It even makes the condition worse here some studies that you can look up if you pause this and you can
Search those studies on pop bed and see the studies that prove that as well
So this is a totally different situation the first one is a
Low immune response and you want to build up your immune system
Well, these people with this condition would do far worse
If they stimulated their immune system
So you want to calm the immune system down you want to decrease inflammatory cytokines you want to decrease
histamines in your body
So you'll have to use a completely different approach
You would have used immune-hancine supplementation that's where some people are on products that they hear about online that oh, I should take
You know vitamin C and and and immune stimulants to prevent that's maybe what that my problem is and they tend to get worse
That's a sign that you're in this second piece the second type of reaction
You want to take products that are going to calm the immune system
Sun balance is a product that is a PEA product with corsetin
Which is known to decrease histamines and decrease IL-6 levels
I AI which is our product that I created for autoimmune disease is a perfect product with curcumin
Resveratrol other in flavonoids to decrease that
Pro-inflammatory response in histamine scavengers and great product with a bunch of different herbs that will decrease histamines and
Decrease those inflammatory cytokines
This is a very different approach and you have to look at it differently
So you got these three things a prolonged immune deficiency will you want to build up your immune system and a
Prolonged or acute immune enhancement what we want to call our immune system
opposite approaches
opposite approaches you have to take an opposite
Approach at dealing with it and then the third one may be something that you have
In conjunction with one of the other two so the third one isn't
one or the other you could have number three and acute prolonged toxic reaction with
a prolonged immune deficiency or with a prolonged immune enhancement
So the toxic reaction is a toxic exposure to vaccine to
the environment to poisons in your environment
There's lots of different sources that go way beyond what we've been experiencing in the last couple years
So adjuvant from vaccines can cause this by proteins can cause this
Released cellular toxins from past exposures to things that you've been exposed to can cause this in endotoxins which are toxins from
Cell damage and cells that are going through lysis and breaking down or bacteria that's breaking down and going through lysis
Those are endotoxins that your body has to clear away
So anything you could do to support liver detox pathways in this case is really your best approach
Think about doing coffee animals think about doing hot packs over your liver think about supporting liver detox pathways
We have our specific detox bundle that was specifically created by me to help pull these things out of your body
That's a lot of different things you don't have to take all of those
But this is a great approach to help pull this stuff out of your body if you've especially had to get
Vaccinated or you're exposed to a lot of people that are vaccinated
This is a great way to protect yourself. So those are our three
Approaches first two are very different in opposite to one another if I have an immune
Deficiency, I want to build my immune system up. That's our cold and flu bundle
If I have immune enhancement
And I'm having these immune reactions where I have a lot of inflammation and such a lot of you might be in that and you are
Treating it wrong
So you want to go off of those immune stimulators for a period of time and treat it by calming the immune system down
So you're really calming the pro and flammatory side of your immune system down when you're taking these
So you're not going to hurt yourself as far as not having an immune system, but you're getting rid of those
Hyper and flammatory chemicals called cytokines in your body
That's our acute
Prologged immune enhancement bundle and then the specific detox bundle for detoxing
Everything that we're exposed to in our environment including the things that we're exposed to now
So hopefully this clarifies things
If you have questions you can look at each one of these different products on our store
And hopefully that will help you explain some things
I know we talked about a lot of stuff here
But go through it a couple of times and we wish you the best. Thanks